[Music]
I'm a Solutions Architect with Google
cloud and to start off with I'm gonna
talk about what a data Lake is how you
would structure your data like on GCP
with a lot of help from bigquery and
then after that double derv a over there
who is a strategic cloud engineer with
Google cloud we'll talk about how you
would operate alized bigquery and then
lastly Tomas Radomski who is also over
there we'll go into detail about how
okano technology by the way
Tomek leads up data engineering at akkad
oh he'll talk about how a kado built out
a data Lake with a lot of help once
again from bigquery I know we don't have
everybody in the room but I'm gonna do a
quick informal survey so by show of
hands how many of you here have either
built out a data Lake already or are
thinking about building out a data Lake
okay I'm not surprised that's good
so this term data Lake is thrown out a
lot it has a lot of meetings to to a lot
of different people what I'd like to do
first is do some level setting on what I
mean by data Lake for the purposes of
this session and I think you'll agree
with most of these characteristics the
first one is this philosophy of storing
everything and what that recognizes is
the fact that we want to guide the
questions we're asking of our data based
on the data that we can collect we want
to collect everything of course within
compliance restrictions and storage
restrictions but yes we do want to
collect everything and once we collect
the data our data Lake has to facilitate
exploration that's how we go from raw
data to refine data products that will
inform us whether it's about business
decisions you know new opportunities
operational efficiencies things of that
nature
and once we surface these data products
we want to be able to bring
a variety of tools to process these data
products of course those sessions about
big queries so it'll feature prominently
and how you do analytics but in addition
we want to be able to allow our data
scientists to use spark MapReduce you
know cloud dataflow which is our
serverless processing engine all of
these tools so with those
characteristics in mind here's a
high-level flow of how things go from
raw data to the refined data products
and this will be kind of a theme at
least during my presentation on this
slide we're gonna focus on the ingest
and store piece we ingest data from a
variety of sources we want to facilitate
batch analytics as well as stream
analytics and when we when it comes time
to store the data I'm gonna say right
off the bat that Google Cloud Storage
also known as GCS is the ideal choice
for the lake itself and you're probably
wondering hey this is a session on
bigquery why is he talking about GCS and
that's because and by the way when Tomac
goes into detail over how they built out
their data like you'll hear that they're
ingesting structure data storing it
directly in bigquery and and doing
analytics with bigquery and that's great
we love we love that two things to keep
in mind the first one is that as your
data volume grows as you go from
hundreds of terabytes to say many many
petabytes of data it makes financial
sense to lifecycle your older data from
bigquery into one of the archival
storage classes that GCS has this way
you can balance cost as well as
analytics capability and then the other
reason is that you know you want to be
able to do the flexible processing that
I talked about sequel is great but once
again you want to bring in SPARC you
want to bring in MapReduce you want to
do predictive analytics and for that GCS
is great it's a great central repository
that integrates well with GCS services
as you'll find out as well as a whole
slew of third-party services
and I mentioned you know working well
with GCS and and bigquery as you would
expect works really well with GCS is as
well for example if you have Averell
files in GCS you can query those files
you know with rich schema and all of
that good stuff directly from bigquery
without first loading that data into
bigquery now having said that for the
vast majority of use cases you actually
want to pull that data into bigquery
first because it gives you a better
performance it gives you more native
querying capability and you'll be happy
to find out that import and export to
and from GCS into bigquery is free and
the last reason to use bigquery and
compare it in combination with GCS is
that they share a compatible security
model they both use GCP Identity and
Access Management this has ramifications
for how you do access control as you'll
find out from double and encryption as
well so if you have a compliance regime
that requires you to use customer
managed encryption keys then you can use
those same keys for encrypting and
decrypting data in both GCS and bigquery
so we talked about ingest let's get into
the other two characteristics that I
talked about there's a lot going on in
this slide so I'm gonna unpack it into
smaller digestible pieces and once again
the question that's gonna guide that is
how do we get from all this raw data
that I talked about to the defined data
products to answer that question let's
break those refined data products into
three categories these are categories
that I feel you know what will help us
guide this discussion so the first one
is this notion of a data Mart this
should be familiar to folks who use
sequel data warehousing but I want to
expand that definition a little bit even
though this is the thing that bigquery
is best known for you know sequel data
warehousing setting up data Mart's but a
lot of customers these days are also
doing Parkay files Avro files and and
you know refining data in that fashion
and exposing them to both internal
external customers if you do that you
use hive you can use MapReduce you can
use bark on top of those files as well
and you can also use serverless
processing with cloud dataflow the
second type of data product is streaming
workflows so you know if you have a
retail e-commerce website and you want
to better understand you know inventory
depletion how customers are navigating
your site you could set up clickstream
you know capture send that to cloud
pub/sub which is our global messaging
service and then you could use cloud
dataflow to grab messages out of pub/sub
and then use bigquery streaming API to
ingest that data directly into bigquery
and what that lets you do is with very
low latency query that data we're
talking a matter of a few seconds this
is pretty powerful and once again
bigquery excels at this and the last
type of data product is predictive
models so whether it's statistical
models machine learning models you know
you could look at the captured raw data
figure out what kind of trends are in
there and set up a tensor flow model and
then import that model into cloud
machine learning engine which is our
server lists machine learning framework
and you know train that with all the
training data you've captured using GPUs
GPUs and then deploy that trained model
into cloud machine learning engine once
again and do inference so those are the
three types of data products one thing I
skipped is how you do mining and
exploration in between so you know
taking all that raw data and coming up
with with with data products you know is
that's in keeping with our philosophy of
letting the data guide the types of
questions we're gonna ask and this has
to be an iterative process we're not
going to be kind of rigid in the types
of schemas that we will expose to our
analysts in order to do that you need an
agile nimble you know way of doing
things and and this is where bigquery
once again can help a lot so without
having to put a
a lot of thought into the type of
schemas that your raw data has you could
load that into bigquery set up a bit
query data set and then your data
scientists could figure out hey what are
the types of trends that this data has
how can we surface more production-ready
schemas in our data Mart's what type of
streaming workflows can we set up and
then also do is trend analysis to figure
out the kinds of predictive models we
can set up so to wrap things up for for
my piece I'd like to go over an example
that kind of captures all of this and
also includes orchestration so let's say
you have a data Lake that has to pull in
a lot of struck unstructured data this
is in contrast to something you'll hear
about from Tomek so let's say you have
videos images speech data this is
something that has been opaque up until
very recently so what you can do now is
send these types of files into one of
our server lists machine learning api's
extract meaningful metadata so if you
have a whole bunch of cat videos you can
send that through our video intelligence
API figure out what types of objects are
in those videos what they're doing store
that metadata and bigquery along with
links to the the actual files themselves
an orchestration is a key piece here
because you're pulling in data on a
daily basis and you have to orchestrate
it so that metadata magically appears in
in the in a system like bigquery so
Claude Composer which is our managed
Apache airflow service is a great tool
to use use here cool so with all of that
said let's hear from double about how
you would operationalize bigquery on GCP
good morning everyone welcome to google
cloud next my name is the elder way and
I'm a strategic cloud engineer in
Google's cloud team so so far we have
talked about how bigquery can be used to
explore your data in a lake now let's
take one step further let's try to
create a data Mart or data warehouse in
bigquery and walk through the process
for that so how do we operationalize
that now first thing in
operationalization is how do you ingest
your workflows or how do you build your
ingestion pipelines with bigquery
depending on your needs you have many
choices there if you want to really
write simple workflows just loading data
files you can use BQ command-line tool
for that if you want to do some kind of
transformations but don't want to do any
coding you can use cloud data prop which
is an excellent tool to do that for more
complex transformations or more of
flexibility you should use cloud
dataflow now first three options that I
have mentioned are mainly used to ingest
data from either your batch files or
either your middleware systems like a
Kafka or cloud pub/sub if you want to
directly ingest from your application
itself
bigquery provides your streaming API
which can be used to directly ingest
data from application to bigquery these
records which are ingested are also
available in your real time - for your
users to query so these are some ways
how you can ingest your data in bigquery
now the data is ingested so natural next
stop is to talk about access control B
query takes a really simple approach
over here you can you can add resources
at organization level project level or
data set level with bigquery all of your
permissions inherit from top to bottom
so if you add somebody an admin at
organization level they'll automatically
be added to all of your projects and all
of your database data sets on the right
hand side you are seeing type of
entities that can be added to bigquery
so for three options over there users
groups and domains can be added to any
of these three levels public and
authorized views are only available at
data set levels if you make any data set
public that becomes available to any GCP
user in the world so this option is
available when you
want to open-source your data or just
make it available for everyone to
consume authorized use basically give
you an option to provide more granular
controls over how your users access data
so if you want to go beyond data set
level you want to apply table level or
row level access you can use authorized
views for that so now you're set up
access how do your users get started so
once your data is ingested good thing
with bigquery is you don't need to do
any kind of tune up any kind of indexing
or sizing up your environment you can
basically get started with with our just
after ingesting your data what your
admins and your DBS can actually do to
help your users Audis go to bigquery
console write some sample queries for
users save them which will be shared
across here you across all of your users
in the project you can make them private
as well but sharing them will start your
analysts much faster also bigquery
supports standard sequel which is
compliant with sequel 2011 so as long as
your users know sequel they're good to
go now some of the organizations have
this central teams whose job is to
manage these curated data sets and all
other teams or other cost centers are
usually you carry those data and create
their own data set on top of that now
with bigquery you get charged for
storage separately and compute
separately and you want to make sure
that your storage costs or your central
group doesn't get charged for querying
by other users or other analysts or
other cost centers what you can do is
with bigquery create a central project
which will keep these curated datasets
create separate projects for your cost
centers and they should use different
billing accounts so that whatever
queering cost they incur they goes to
their billing accounts and your central
group just pays for your storage costs
also Kathy just mentioned how you can
explore your data using bigquery and
data lab but it also provides a lot of
connectors for tools like tableau Locker
and data studio to visualize your data
or run your reporting workloads on top
of it now your users are consuming this
data so your admins need to monitor your
environment bigquery provides a lot of
matrix in stackdriver itself to look at
the health of your environment
I have mentioned some of these over here
which can be used by your billing ad
means your storage admins or any kind of
resource admins to look look at how your
environment is doing they can also set
up alerts and notifications on these on
these metrics so that whenever the value
of any matrix goes up or below their
threshold they can they can get notified
for that let's talk about compliance
so from an auditing perspective bigquery
provides mainly two types of logs admin
activity and data access activity admin
activity keeps information about schema
change in schema creation data at
creation table creation etc these logs
are available for 400 days data access
activity locks are available for 30 days
and that keeps information about who is
accessing what kind of data or what kind
of data is getting modified if you want
if you have a need and you want to
change change how many how many days the
data gets written today what you can do
is you can export these logs into Google
Cloud Storage or B query itself and you
can set your custom duration over there
if you want to and look at these logs on
a real-time basis you can always stream
these logs into cloud pub/sub and attach
your application to cloud pub/sub to be
able to do that now your users are using
is your admins are monitoring it so of
course they'll find new use case
patterns and new information that they
did not know when they built it so how
do you optimize based on what you know
so when it comes to optimization with
bigquery there are three major areas
which I would like to cover storage cost
and compute with storage so lot of data
warehouses have si lays to keep data for
X number of days that could be hundred
days 200s 300s whatever and after that
team has to remove that data either by
building it in process or or doing it
manually with bigquery what you can do
is you can actually set expiration time
for any data set table or partition and
bigquery will automatically remove that
that data and clear up a storage for you
from a cost perspective one thing I say
is if you have already loaded data in
bigquery and you are not modifying it
just keep it in bigquery because if you
keep the
data in bigquery either bql table or
partition for 90 days and don't change
it for 90 days
big query automatically charges you much
less for its storage cost because it
considers it settle long term storage
again you don't need to do anything it
just stays there and you'll get charged
much less compared to how you will get
charged for active storage also try to
use partition tables because whenever
you are using partition tables and you
use write filters with bigquery you scan
much less number of bytes and you get
charged much less compared to scanning
entire table also sometimes you don't
know how big the table is and you want
to just get a feel of how much your
query will cost before running as query
you can actually schedule a dry run for
query and that way big query will give
you some estimate about how much is
going to cost you so good way for you to
just try before buying it also if you
are running same query again and again
and I see that happening a lot in your
reporting workloads bigquery tries to
read that information from cache and you
don't get charged for reading data from
cache so bigquery tries to be on its own
now sometimes you have users who are new
to bigquery or new to organization and
you really don't know how they are going
to work with bigquery and as this is a
pay-as-you-go your charges get much goes
up as soon as they start using it and
you want to make sure you want to
control how much data they access or how
much how much cost they incur on a daily
basis you can set custom quota in
bigquery UI itself for any particular
user or any particular project and that
way they will never blow up your budget
or they will never go out of the cost
that you had decided for them to use now
from compute side I always say start
optimizing your queries make sure you
use write queries and what I mean by
that is B query is a columnar database
so that being said you should don't try
to use select star with that try to use
only those columns which you need for
your aggregation or any kind of queries
try to use partition tables and write
partition filters with that also try to
denormalize tables whenever you can
because cost of D normalization and
storage is much less compared to cost of
join also as you might know bigquery
usually charges for pay-as-you-go
that's so by default
shann and what I mean by that is
whenever you create any project by
default you get up to 2,000 slots and
what I mean by slots is you can think of
slot as a computing unit that you get
with bigquery you get up to 2,000
computing cores of computing units with
bigquery by default for your project so
what happens is if you are running one
query it we can take up to 2,000 slots
if you are running multiple queries that
can also take up to 2,000 slots so if
you have more important queries and less
important queries in the same project
what you can do is you can actually set
those less important queries as and run
them as batch queries that way they'll
get deep prioritize they will still
finish but they will get D prioritized
and you're actually important query
which have strict SLS will run first now
you might be coming from some large
large organizations and you might have
very large analytics workloads in that
scenario you can go to the second option
that I have mentioned which is fixed
slots lot of the organizations have like
very high analytics workloads and they
can actually come to us and buy
additional number of fixed slots so by
default you get 2,000 but you can buy up
to any number and that will be a fixed
number of slots for your organization or
your project which fixed number of slots
you it also controls the cost in a way
that you always know how much your
monthly compute cost is going to be with
bigquery so because once you once you
buy a fixed number of slots there is no
pay-as-you-go you can run any number of
queries and you'll still get billed for
same how many slots you have purchased
also one thing one option which becomes
available and we call it hierarchical
slots is something that you know comes
with fixed plots and I'm going to give
you an example of it in the next slide
so let's assume you have four projects
R&D dashboards ETL and ad hoc bottom
three projects are important projects
they have strict SLS you want to make
sure they finish on time all the jobs
for them finish on time ad or project is
mainly a playground area or sandbox for
your new users where they just want to
try things you don't want to incur any
additional cost for that ad hoc projects
if you buy fixed number of slots what
you can do is you can configure this top
project ad hoc project in a way that it
uses resources only when they are
available on bottom
project so any of the projects below any
of the projects below have any slots
available this a dog project can take
those slots from those projects and
start using those resources so that's
that way you can share your deep route
or prioritize or D prioritize your
projects as well in bigquery but you
need to have fixed number of slots for
that
so these are some ways you can optimize
your cost or storage or compute in
bigquery now before I asked Tomic to
come on stage and present his Okada case
I'm just going to summarize what we have
discussed so far so as Cathy mentioned
bigquery works seamlessly with data Lake
you can explore your data you can do
mining and exploration right over there
once you have built your data Mart you
can centrally manage your resources
through Identity and Access Management
and you can monitor them using
stackdriver when it comes to flexibility
and compute needs big query gives you a
really great flexibility regarding what
you want to do when so if you need more
compute or you can buy additional number
of fixed slots if you just need more
storage just keep keep your default
option and you'll be fine last thing I
wanted to mention was you can always
share with Vic query and the way it
works you can always share and
collaborate your data compute as well as
your queries across your users in your
organization very seamlessly that being
said I'm going to ask Tomic to come on
stage and present how Accardo is using
bigquery also one announcement I wanted
to make is this session is Dory enabled
which is a our live questions platform
so you can go on your app and if you
have any questions you can put those
questions in this sessions
questionnaires thank you so much
thanks al
good morning everyone and thanks for
coming my name is Tom extrados key I'm
getting data engineering gado-gado you
have heard quite a lot of useful
information about products that are
available in Google cloud platform and
how you can use them to store and
analyze your data now I would like to
tell you how in Okada we combine those
components together to build our data
like not sure if you have heard about
Okada before but let just me quickly
introduce to you what we are doing so we
are the world's largest online only
supermarket we deliver more or less 50
thousands of products to more than six
hundreds of thousands of active
customers in UK but what is important we
build our solution in-house for example
robotics in our warehouses front and
application back-end systems everything
the heart of Okada our highly automated
warehouses which we call CFC customer
fulfillment center so you can imagine
that on the grid of size of football
field there are hundreds of boats moving
currents and products doing some
operations just to fulfill orders of our
customers but Okada is not only CFC we
created ecommerce end-to-end solution
that of course includes delivery systems
customer center systems so basically
everything we needed to succeed in this
business as you can imagine we collect
quite a lot of data from those systems
and we use them to leverage our business
so for example we have recommendation
systems fraud detection out of my
automatic classification of image that
is using deep network deep learning but
this is just half of our story so on one
side
Okada is the online supermarket but on
the other side let's for a second
imagine that you are traditional
retailer and you'd like to go online
this opportunity is called Okada smart
platform so the idea is that we are
selling our technology as a service at
the moment we have a pleasure to
work with several retailers in Europe
and North America to be able to start
new environments for new retailers we
moved our solution to cloud and the
process of moving to cloud gave us quite
unique opportunity to rethink and
redesign our systems and that also
includes data architecture so before
moving to cloud we've been working with
some on-premise solution like or at
greenplum different on-prem file
storages and it's a challenge because
you need to plan your capacity what data
is most important for you what to do if
you are running out of storage how to
implement your attention policy so we
didn't want to care about that anymore
so we wanted to build the solution that
is able to store all the data we need
secondly we wanted to have the data
processing so easy that everyone in
organization can do it in most of
organizations there are some dedicated
data teams like Big Data data
engineering machine learning teams we of
course also have such teams but they are
mostly working on two keys best
practices and enablement and the idea is
that we would like to enable everyone in
the organization to be able to process
the data and to do that you need really
simple and coherent solution so we run a
couple of proof-of-concept and at some
point we tested bigquery mmm you have
heard quite a lot of world bigquery but
let me just quickly tell you what was
important to us so first of all it's
extremely easy to use you don't need to
worry about DB tuning so you don't need
to maintain indexes materialized views
hundreds of parameters tuned memory
structure storage structures you just
load your your data in you can query in
the query you pay for two things for
storage and for querying your data and
it depends on the volume of data your
cores are scanning but it's quite
transparent you have good control over
it it's
easy to enable your Billings and there
are some things you can do to reduce the
cost of using the solution and it has
been covered by dhawal it works quite
well with Google Cloud Storage so
basically if you have a lot of
unstructured data it's probably a good
idea to store it on Google Cloud storage
but there are some products that you can
use in Google cloud to extract structure
information and stir it in bigquery in
general we don't have a lot of
unstructured data so we are storing
everything in bigquery so this is our
main data leak solution maybe the most
important part
its case endless so basically you can
imagine that under the hood you have the
processing power of Google Data Centers
we've bought grid computation Colossus
file system Jupiter Network so almost no
way to exhaust those resources and the
last thing quite important what is data
locality we at the moment operate mostly
in you that's why we wanted to have our
data stored in you and this is something
that bigquery gives you out of the box
you can choose the location it can be US
Europe Asia whatever you need so we
decided the bigquery is going to be the
brain of our data like but we needed a
simple approach of loading the data into
bigquery and with write even sourcing so
just to remind you our applications are
running in the cloud and we use
microservices architecture so those
micro services are doing some business
operations and that of course generate
some data so idea is that we pack this
data into event and send it to the cloud
so for example custom a customer makes
an order there is an event sent the
order is picked or delivered there is an
event sent the payment is taken from the
account event sent and all those events
are sent to the streaming crowd we use
kinases at the moment now you may ask
why we are not using pops-up from Google
and that's because when we start
working on this architecture pops up was
not a viable though okay so all our
events are sent to stream in the cloud
and from there we stream it into
bigquery so we created real-time
application on Apache beam it's running
on data flow and it made
responsibilities just reading the events
from kinetics and streaming it to big
quorum so this has been covered by Carty
but at the moment we are using streaming
approach only that way all the data from
our systems the data is a viable in our
lake in a matter of seconds why we
decided to run even processing on data
flow to be honest at the very beginning
with write spark streaming it was
working pretty well but we had too many
issues so first of all we had problems
with h.a so basically what to do if your
workers are failing or master node is
failing and especially what to do to
make sure that in case of failure we are
not used losing any events and secondly
we needed out of scaling our workload
ver eyes so at some point we are sending
thousands of events per minute a little
bit later hundreds of thousands and
those problems has been solved by data
flow for us as mentioned before we are
using structured data and to have a good
control over what we are sending to our
lake we introduced another component
which we call data registry its App
Engine application in which every type
of the event that enters our system must
be registered by register I mean the
user need to define the schema so what
are the fields inside this event those
fields are mapped into columns in
bigquery tables what are the data types
and some metadata information like even
name even group which we used to wrote
this event into particular location in
our data link this is also our data
governance tone because every single
piece of information that enters our
data leg is stored here so basically you
can run some text search to see where
your data from where it's sent and where
it is routed in bigquery so let's talk
about our data model so as mentioned we
have our event which we call row event
and what is important this is the
private area for the team that is
producing this particular piece of
information no one else in organization
is allowed to read row events which are
basically mapped to bigquery tables to
expose this data through the rest of the
organization we created a kind of data
level API so introduced so called data
objects and derive objects so for
creation of the data objects in most
cases this is just a view or physical
table that is refreshed a couple of
times a day our responsible data
producers so teams that are producing
this information so basically this is
how we enable the whole organization
data processing so teams are responsible
for creating the views the views are
combining those information from
microservices
by doing unions joins the duplication
aggregation whatever makes sense to
create a kind of business entity
meaningful business entity to do that we
run quite a lot of workshops to show
people how to use bigquery demonstrate
some most important aspects of bigquery
and teach them how to process the data
in general so data object and derive
objects are quite similar the main
difference is the derived object may
blend data from multiple systems for
example order management data with
payments data so this is a kind of data
Mart that fits on specific business
purpose and derived objects we are
sometimes exporting to Google Cloud
storage and this is how we make it
available for our
retailers to be downloaded and analyzed
so just to sum up events this private
implementation of our data internal API
data objects so this is how we are
exposing the data internally at external
API derive object they are also short
with retailers we work with to do this
transformation from raw event to data
object and to derived object we needed a
kind of workflow scheduler or
orchestration engine and a couple of
years ago we couldn't find anything that
satisfied our needs so we created our
own solution we call it quarry manager
so this is the application where you can
create tasks like execute the query
create a view extract some data to
Google storage you can combine those
tasks in workflows and schedule them but
at the moment there is a new component
in Google Cloud called Google component
and it basically solves the similar
business problem so it is Wartrol
orchestration engine okay so we have
three level of data classification first
is the type of the object that I has
mentioned so row events data objects and
derive objects second is business or
subject area so what is the content in
this particular table and we figure out
a number of areas this is just the
sample with seborrhea so we classify all
our data that way so for example if you
would like to take a look on some
payment information you can find them in
the area payment details and the third
level of classic classification relates
to security we have three levels public
so this is a kind of data that can be
open sourced at the moment we are not
doing that but the platform is ready for
that
second level is restricted so everyone
in the organization should have access
to this data if needed and confidential
this a bit more secured that's because
this kind of
information may contain some sensitive
information like PII data of our
customers and combining those three
classifications together we created a
convention how we are naming our data
sets so data set in the quick query is
an aggregation of DB objects views and
tables and it has been mentioned but by
devil but just me repeat you grant
accesses on data set level so basically
you grant access to every single table
and viewed there is there is in this
particular data set so that's why let's
take a look on the example for example
the second data set order details it
means that we have information about
orders their data is not derived so the
information are not blended with
different systems it's purely about
orders and restricted so no PII inside
everyone the organization can use it so
this is how by just taking a look on the
name of the data set you know more or
less what is inside so this is basically
how we are governing our data how we are
loading the data to our alag and how we
are controlling that and transforming
our data if you are interested in
building data legs on GCP i would
recommend taking a look on materials
linked here for example article or some
QuickStart guides if you are not very
familiar with bigquery there is quite a
lot of resources courser also study it's
a lot of materials and there are also
some related sessions during this
conference so if this is something that
interests you I would recommend to join
them just letting you know that my
colleagues from Okada are also
delivering two sessions so if you are
interested for example how we are doing
machine learning just after plant there
is one session about building our cloud
ml infrastructure and on first there
there's another how we use AI to
leverage retail business so that's
basically all thank you it was a
pleasure to have a chance to talk to you
[Music]